MEHRAN NAZIR: Welcome to Stream
Work Makes the Dream Work.
Streaming on Linux is hard,
but it doesn't have to be.
Data flow simplifies it for you.
You can start today, and you
don't have to be a developer.
We're going to cover
three topics today--
how do I start, how do I
scale, and how do I optimize.
But firstly, who are you?
Someone with data
in your title--
data engineer, data
analyst, data scientist,
someone who knows that real time
data is the key to unlocking
new experiences?
Someone who wants to
start using the newest
features and isn't afraid
to use some of the products
that we are going to
be showcasing today?
And someone who might
be familiar with SQL?
Python and Java are a
bonus but not required.
My name is Mehran Nazir,
and I'm a product manager
with Dataflow.
Before we dive into
the presentation,
let's introduce Beam and
Dataflow for our newcomers.
Beaming and Dataflow
work together.
Beam is the open source SDK
used to express [INAUDIBLE]
processing pipeline, while
Dataflow is the execution
engine.
Beam has an open source
programming model by the Apache
project, is a top Apache
project by developer activity,
includes a unified
backing streaming model.
So for folks that are coming
from the [INAUDIBLE] world
and have to maintain
two different systems,
you just have one--
and offers a unique flexibility
with Runner and languages,
meaning you could
write your pipelines
in the SDK of your choice,
with the desired backend
of your choice.
Dataflow, on the other hand,
is an execution engine that
runs Apache Beam pipelines.
It's fully managed
in serverless and can
scale to millions of QPS with
no management and no tuning.
It offers accuracy, with
exactly-once streaming
guarantees and
offers the separation
of compute and storage with our
shuffle and streaming engine
services.
So let's get into this.
How do I start?
To motivate this
journey, we're going
to take the perspective of a
data scientist named Serena.
Serena is a data scientist
that analyzes data
produced by data pipelines.
She creates and maintains
reports and dashboards--
and sets up and maintains the
company's data architecture.
Some of the tools and
skills she has include
SQL, Python, in particular
libraries like scikit
learn, pandas, matplotlib.
And she likes using Jupyter
Notebooks to prototype
and explore data ad hoc.
But Serena's tasks
come with challenges.
She has to run these analyses
on a scheduled basis,
whether that be daily,
weekly, monthly.
And that creates a fair
bit of manual toil.
She has to interface with a
number of different production
systems, some of which
she's not familiar with.
And sharing pipeline code
is manual and subject
to human error.
And then, if data
doesn't arrive on time,
she doesn't have the skills
to optimize and troubleshoot,
if necessary.
Serena discovers steaming
analytics with Dataflow,
but in taking a
look at it, she's
immediately inundated with
a lot of new information.
She has to learn about a
new Beam programming model.
She has to understand
what Runners are--
and hearing terms like
Dataflow, Flink, Spark.
She's new to concepts
like windowing,
watermarks, and triggers.
And ideally, she'd have
a sandbox environment
to test these concepts.
Enter Jupyter Notebooks, which
is perfect for her use case.
She's familiar with them,
and it allows her a place
to learn about Beam concepts as
she iteratively builds her Beam
pipeline in a safe environment.
Usually, notebooks have been
good for analyzing batch data
sets, but Dataflow has built
new streaming extensions
for notebook environments.
Interactive Beam will bring
new functionality that
allow you to record sources, as
well as interactively explore
intermediate data
transformations,
called PCollections.
This will help new learners
pick up the basics of Beam.
But not only that, it'll
help experienced developers
prototype pipelines step by
step in a read eval print loop
workflow.
So let's see this in action.
To get started with
Beam notebooks,
Serena will navigate to
the Dataflow console--
and using the left hand panel,
navigate to the notebooks page.
She'll see a list
of the notebooks
she's created, specifically
with the Apache environment.
And if this screen
looks familiar to her,
she'll realize that this is
actually identical to the AI
platform notebooks interface.
Beam notebooks is built
on top of that platform,
meaning any features available
in AI Platform notebooks
is also available
through Beam notebooks.
She'll click on the
New Instance button
at the top, which will show an
option for an Apache Beam VM.
What this VM will
include will be
all the necessary Beam
libraries and packages
for the interactive
capabilities,
as well as some
examples that we'll
go through in just a moment.
You have the ability to
select your region, your zone,
and network, if desired.
And I'm ready, I can hit Create.
That process takes a few
minutes to initialize,
so what we'll do
instead is to navigate
to a JupyterLab instance
that has already
been created for Serena.
So I'm going to click
on the open JupyterLab
tab, which will navigate
to the Apache Beam notebook
experience.
And what you'll see when
you first start is a read
me that includes a
directory of examples.
We pre-populated
the Beam containers
with four examples
that successively
build on one another.
The first one is a word
count that demonstrates
a simple batch pipeline.
It's the second example
is an extension of that
into streaming, where
as opposed to reading
from a batch data
source, it is reading
from a streaming Pub/Sub topic.
And the third example is more
advanced streaming use case,
where we are looking at taxi
ride data coming New York City.
And then lastly,
we have a notebook
that shows how you launch a
Dataflow job from the notebook
environment.
So as I enter the
directory of examples
and really focus my attention
on streaming word count as well
as the Dataflow
word count, I want
to level us at the five
things that Serena is really
looking for in her first
foray into streaming.
She wants to learn five things.
She wants to learn one, how to
read from a streaming source.
Two, she wants to better
understand windowing
and how to explore that
data in the context of Beam.
Three, she want to learn how to
write that to a streaming sync.
Forth, she wants to see what
that graph will look like--
that topology, what will it
look like when it's submitted
to the Dataflow runner.
And then lastly, she
wants to know, again,
how can she launch what's
created in the notebook
environment into the
Dataflow service.
The streaming word count
example is a good starting point
for understanding
how she can do that.
So the first thing
she'll do is obviously
she will import these
libraries, all the relevant ones
for Apache Beam, as well as
some other utility libraries.
And after that, she's ready
to start setting up options
to create the
streaming pipeline.
The next cell she'll
see is something
she's not familiar with, an
interactive option called
capture duration.
What that allows you to do is
set the data capture duration
for your source recording.
It can be set in
terms of seconds.
It could also be set
in terms of size.
But again, it gives you the
ability to assign how much data
you want to be able to capture
from your streaming source--
again, given that streaming
sources are infinite,
this allows you to
allow a cap for that.
Another important
option that we've also
introduced for streaming
data is around the ability
to enable capture replay.
What this will allow you
to do is, if you always
want to see these freshest data,
you could set this to false--
so that all the data is new.
But as you might know, one
of the difficult things
about notebook
environments in general
is, how do I recreate streaming
experiments, especially when
data is coming in all the time.
The ability to
reproduce experiments
is already difficult. The
ability to turn this to true
allows you to, again, turn
a streaming source basically
into a batch--
and allows you to project
on one data source to,
again, set a constant,
in terms of the data that
is being ingested.
So now that we've talked a
little bit about what you could
do with source recording,
let's go actually
into the meat of this
pipeline-- and actually start
building it from the ground up.
The first thing
you'll see is I'm
going to be able to read
words from this Pub/Sub
transformation.
I've aligned this
cell, and you'll
see that this read
is essentially
going to map to the transformed,
when I actually submit it
to the Dataflow runner.
The first thing I do
when I see those words
is, I want to be able
to windows those.
I want to be able to assign
each to specific time windows.
And as you can tell
from this cell,
I am assigning them
to 10 second windows.
And what I want to do
with each of those windows
is count the number
of occurrences of each
of these words per window.
And that's what the
next cell will do.
So now that I've basically
created the first three
transformations
in my pipeline, I
want to take a chance
to actually now start
understanding what I'm
doing and explore my data.
So that's what I have
the IB.show function.
This, again, is a
functionality that
allows you to include window
information as a parameter.
And not only will you
see the number of times
particular words are being
counted in a given window,
but you'll also see the
specific window panes
that they are associated with.
As I scroll down,
you'll also see
that I have the ability
to also visualize
data that is coming in through
the streaming data source.
And we've built a few helpful
tools that will allow you,
again, visualize the
distribution, as well
as the occurrence of these words
in a more illustrative context.
What I want to do now
is take that word--
again, I want to be
able to count based
on a normalized set of counts--
and not, again, necessarily
count based on capitalization.
So what I'll create is a map
function that lower cases each
of the words.
And once I've done that, I
use the show function again
to count the number of
words that I'm seeing
in each of these windows.
And the last thing
that we've created
is a new function
called collect,
which allows you
to cast that data
into the form of an
appendaged data frame
and allow you to interact with
that data in a context that's
a lot more familiar.
So now that I've, kind
of, taken a look at--
one, how to read from
a streaming source,
now that I understand
that what windowing is
and how to explore that data.
And I've now gotten a
chance to do those things,
now I want to start actually
thinking about how I launch it
in the [INAUDIBLE] service.
And what I'll do here
is, I'll switch over
to the data for
word count example.
When I click on
this-- again, this
is this repeating the
word count examples
from the initial examples.
But all quickly jump into
the interesting parts.
Now that I am thinking about
launching into the Dataflow
service, I want to think about
actually writing this data
to an output data set.
And by going through
these specific cells,
you'll see that I will write
this to GCS after I specified
a few options.
You'll see that I've now
indicated GS bucket, which
will contain the output of
this streaming data pipeline.
And once I have created this out
of this write transformation,
which will write
this to text file
and write it to a
specific GCS location,
I want to now see what will
this look like on the Dataflow
service.
That's where I'll use the
IB.show graph function, which
will give me an example of what
my topology will look like.
And then, as you can tell, it's
exactly as I've described it.
You'll read data from
a Pub/Sub source,
that will cast it to a specific
peak collection called words.
I'll count those and write
them to cloud storage,
but I'll also create a
separate branch which
will lowercase the words and
count unique instances that are
irrespective of capitalization.
Now that I've, again,
verified that graph,
I can now use the Dataflow
runner to run that pipeline.
And when I run this
cell right here,
I can now quickly click here
and navigate specifically
to the job that I've written
in the Dataflow console.
And with that, Serena now has
gotten the entire top to bottom
with streaming data sources,
using a Beam notebook.
Serena doesn't only
have to use notebooks.
She can also use SQL to
launch streaming jobs.
Dataflow SQL, a GA
capability, allows
you to launch Dataflow pipelines
from the BigQuery you want.
She can select sources and
sinks from Pub/Sub, to BigQuery,
to GSA.
It has a visual schema editor
to help inspect the data.
Some of the cool things she can
do with this capability include
real time dashboards
from BigQuery,
as well as create other sources
for other streaming pipelines.
Now that Serena has
mastered the fundamentals,
how does she scale?
Her team wants to
use streaming now
for data transport, simple
transformation needs,
as well as real time analytics.
But her teammates have
different requirements.
They all have different sources
and sinks, not all of them
have programming
skills, and they all
prefer to work from
different environments,
whether that be the UI, the
command line, or the 90E.
The solution?
Serena can use Flex templates,
a feature that we have recently
launched into beta.
With Flex templates, she
can turn any pipeline
into a template that can
be used by other teammates.
You just can take that
template and execute it
with their own arbitrary
parameters passed in.
They could do this from the
UI, from the command line,
or by passing in a
request with the REST API.
We'll now go through a walk
through of Flex templates,
which will show how we
containerize the Dataflow
pipeline, building the
Flex template itself,
then launching it from the UI.
Before Serena can use Flex
templates to share her pipeline
with her teammates, she has
to first author a pipeline.
So we'll start our
demo by looking
at the pipeline she's authored.
This is a Python
template available online
that is ingesting a stream of
positive and negative reviews.
And as you can look at the
statistics helper function,
it is returning URL, the number
of reviews returned by a URL,
an average score for those
URLs, and the oldest and most
recent version of those reviews.
And if you look at
the pipeline itself,
you'll see it's a very
simple read from Pub/Sub,
a transcription of
bytes to string,
as well as a parsing of
the JSON messages itself.
It windows that data
into given intervals
that will slice that data
in the specified window
duration, group those URLs, and
then run that statistic helper
function.
And as you can tell,
there are a list
of arguments that are listed
at the end of the pipeline that
are going to be used for passing
in as a template parameter.
So now that we've
looked at the pipeline,
we're going to use Docker
to build that template.
So I'm going to switch over
to the shell window and copy
and paste a build command.
And what this is doing
is building that pipeline
into a container.
This G Cloud command is
essentially roughly equivalent
to authenticating into
the Docker service,
building that Docker
container using the image,
as well as pushing that to
the Google Container Registry.
And once we are
concluded, you'll
see that our pipeline
has successfully been
turned into a Docker container.
So now that we have it in
the container registry,
we are one step short of
turning it into a Flux template.
Before we can do that, we have
to create a template spec file,
which includes the
name, description,
and input parameters.
So I'll flip back
to my text editor
and see what this container
spec file looks like.
You'll see that it has
a name, a description,
as well as a name label and help
text for the given parameters.
What my parameters
will include will
be a Pub/Sub input subscription,
a BigQuery output table,
as well as a user
specified window interval.
As you can also tell, I can also
create some validation around
whether these specific
parameters are optional or not.
So now that we're ready
to actually build the flux
template, I'm to quickly copy
and paste my Flex template
command, and I will
go back to my shell.
And once again, I will use a
G Cloud beta command, which
was recently created
for Flex templates,
and build a container.
And what we'll see,
in just a few moments,
is successfully saving
this container spec
in this Flux template
file, which I will
be allowed to call in the UI.
So I can copy and paste
this directory right here
and go back to the UI.
So I'm back in the
Dataflow console,
and in the jobs list page,
I can see at the very top
a button for creating
a job from template.
I'm going to navigate to that.
And I'll see that I have the
ability to specify a name.
So we'll call this Serena
teammate Pub/Sub to BigQuery.
And I have the ability
to select a template.
What you also see is a
list of Google provided
templates, which allow
you to do some very
simple things for streaming,
as well as batch and utility
functions.
But for the sake
of this example,
we're going to focus primarily
on the custom template.
If you remember, we
have a GS location
for that Flex template.
I'm going to copy and
paste that into here.
And once I've seen that--
I've seen that
validate, I'll see
that description that I specify
in the container spec file
is located here, and the
required parameters are
found right here.
And now, my teammates can
now use the same template
that I've created, on behalf
of, Serena with the organization
to, again, drive, standardize,
and more broadly, enable
Dataflow for a
streaming organization.
And in the event that you do not
want to confine this to the UI,
you'll see at the
very bottom, we
have also the ability to
create the equivalent rest,
as well as the
equivalent command line.
So again, if you want to be
able to launch a Dataflow
job from your own
environment, you
have the ability to also just
do that directly from the UI
and enable your organization
to use Flex templates.
Serena has now solidified
her Dataflux expertise,
and she's been able to
share it with teammates.
The final mission for her--
how does she optimize
her pipelines?
Serena needs various
things to help
understand what is
happening in her data
processing environment,
monitoring observability
tools, logging,
statistics and counters,
and alerts to know if
pipelines fall behind
or violate their SLOs.
The great thing
about Dataflow is,
we offer these tools
right out of the box.
We all very rich
observability experience
that includes relative
time series metrics,
logs, and configuration
information.
And we've also recently
launched a manage pipelines view
to help you understand how your
recurring Dataflow jobs are
running and quickly identify
if your data sets are not
being processed in time.
So let's flip back to the user
interface for our third demo.
To demonstrate how we're going
to use the new observability
experience to optimize
your Dataflow job,
we're going to navigate
to the Dataflow console.
The first screen you'll
see is the jobs list page,
which, again, is a listing of
all your jobs, sorted by type
as well as status and the
ability to filter those jobs.
We're going to
focus our attention
on a retail application
that we've open sourced.
What this application
is doing is reading data
from a website in mobile apps.
It is also collecting
transaction information
from on prem systems, like a
brick and mortar location, as
well as collecting
information from inventory
to track the inventory
levels of a specific product.
And its joining that information
in running computations.
I'm going to click on that job.
And it's loading, I'll also
mention that this application
is fully open source.
So I do encourage you
to look at the source
code for this
application for yourself.
The first thing you'll
see is the job graph.
The job graph is the data
folder's interpretation
of your business logic.
It presents this
topology for you,
to, again, review the
entirety of your application.
As I've already mentioned,
what this application is doing
is reading from
multiple sources.
It's processing
multiple streams of data
and writing to different syncs.
At the very top, you'll
see the re-transformations.
You'll see that it's reading
a click stream of data coming
from websites and mobile apps--
a transaction stream,
which is reading data
from on prem systems--
for example, brick
and mortar locations.
And then lastly,
a stream of data
that is tracking the levels
of inventory available.
Each of these streams have
respective processing buckets.
And at the very end,
you'll see, after a number
of different computations are
made, as well as some counts,
we are writing to a
sync, like BigQuery,
for the consumption of
another team to run analysis,
as well as to Pub/Sub for
consumption by other pipelines.
You'll see a little arrow
next to some of these boxes.
And what that's really
doing is condensing
a lot of information.
When I click on the
Process Click Stream,
you'll see a pretty
significant expansion,
with an explanation of what
each of these steps are doing.
Again, this is business logic
that's been expressed by you,
and you'll see things like
clean data, mapping elements,
filtering that data, as
well as computing account--
to see which products
are selling the best.
And then once that combination
is made, writing to BigQuery.
But if I want to
get a better sense
for how specific
steps are performing,
I can click on that step.
And what you'll see
on the right here
is step information,
information with regard
to the throughput of
that data, as well as
the output collections.
Again, you'll be able
to identify specifically
what steps might be problematic
and dig a little deeper
from there.
And one last thing
I'll say about the job
graph in this
specific splash page
is, you'll have a Job Info
panel on the right, which
will allow you to collect
important metadata
about your job, including job
ID, the SDK version, location--
specific information with
regards to the metrics,
the resources being consumed.
This will have a direct
relation to the cost
of the pipeline itself, as
well as the pipeline options
that you've selected
for your pipeline.
We've recently announced
a job metrics tab.
And this is what
we are referring
to as the observability dash.
This is what you want to
use to optimize your job
but also to diagnose
issues that might arise.
You'll see specific
graphs that are in line--
data freshness showing
the watermark of your data
and to identify whether
data is falling behind
for whatever reason.
System latency, which
will show, again,
if there's a specific
bottleneck in your system.
You'll see an auto
scaling graph.
This specific application
is only showing one worker.
So it's not really showing
the dynamism of Dataflow,
but if you have an
application that
is looking at multiple workers
with varying degrees of volume,
that will also show in the
amount of workers that are
being provisioned for your job.
You'll also see
the same throughput
that we mentioned
on a per step level.
But what's very helpful
about this specific table
is that now you are looking
at the entirety of your job--
and now the ability to sort
your steps by throughput,
and then quickly
identify specifically
where you might have bottlenecks
in your business logic.
You'll see CPU
utilization, which
will also chart the amount
of CPU being used by workers.
And then lastly, you'll
see a worker air lock
count, which, again, allows you
to see where specific errors
are occurring on your workers.
I think another
good tip here is,
you'll see that, when
I hover over the chart,
I'll see a gray dashed line,
which will also showcase itself
in the charts above,
in CPU realization.
And what that allows you
to do is very quickly
draw a correlation between when
an error might be happening
and what might be happening
on your CPU utilization,
as well as your throughput.
Another tool that I'll
also mention in this
is the time selecting tool.
And by default,
you'll see six hours.
But you can actually look
back as far as 730 days.
We'll just take a look at your
data over the last seven days.
And what you'll see is a
varying degree of throughput,
just as you would see
as a retail application,
you'll see varying degrees
of volume of user traffic.
And that's represented in this
graph, in the throughput graph.
Again, if you more prefer to
see the amount of data that's
being written in terms
of gigabytes in size,
you also have the
ability to select
estimated bytes per second.
And the last thing
I'll also mention
is, we also have a logs
panel that includes job logs,
worker logs, and a direct
integration with our job error
reporting tool, which will
allow you to do more meta
analysis on specific errors
that might be causing
a backlog in your processing.
So in summary, what we covered
today was ways that you just
can optimize your
Dataflow pipeline
using the job graph, job
metrics, and the job and worker
logs.
But not only is it a crucial
tool for optimization but also
for diagnosing problems.
Dataflow pipelines will
always present challenges
due to the shape of data and the
always changing nature of data
processing in real time.
But the entire
[INAUDIBLE] experience
allows you to get that as
quickly and efficiently as
possible.
So let's summarize what
we've covered today.
How do I start?
You can start with Dataflow
with notebooks or Dataflow SQL.
How do I scale?
We can scale our knowledge
and organizations
with Flex templates.
And how do I optimize?
We can maximize the
performance of our jobs
with the new
observability experience.
But note that this
is only a fraction
of what Dataflow has to offer.
We can also start our
journey to Dataflow
with Google provided templates,
that I shared in the demo.
For scaling, we have Shuffle
and Streaming Engine,
which can scale your
job to millions of QPS
with no code change required.
We have tools to help optimize
your pipelines even more.
And if you're ready to go take
your pipeline into production,
we published a brand
new white paper
on building production
ready data pipelines.
To use Dataflow, you have
to use the Apache SDK.
And to that end,
there are lots of ways
you can build on your
Beam knowledge base.
We have ID exercises
called Katas.
We have Qwiklabs.
We have code samples.
And we have a retail
application that's
been open source,
the same application
that I presented
in the third demo.
And not only that, we have a
thriving developer community
in the Beam world.
This presentation
will be published
alongside the recording.
Now, I would strongly
recommend using this
as a reference for the beginning
of your Beam and Dataflow
journey.
In case you want to
check out what else is
new in data analytics, we
have dozens of sessions
that are ready for you.
But if you're interested in
more on s streaming analytics,
I would recommend DA101, Easy
Access to Streaming Analytics
and DA209, Real Time AI,
showing some of our advancements
with Dataflow and machine
learning applications.
Thank you for your time today.
I'm looking forward to seeing
you start your streaming
journey on Dataflow.